on l'appelle ici le petit roland garros
halle atp challenger de blois se joue
sur terre battue il fait partie des
quatorze tournois qui comptent en france
son attractivité repose pour beaucoup
sur la participation de joueurs
remarquer durant l'année pour leurs
performances comme celle de l'espagnol
marcel granollers classée 57e mondiale
qui a déclaré forfait vendredi
il est inscrit au dernier moment et donc
personne l'a sollicité pas moins ni
personne d'autre donc il faisait le toit
me school dernièrement et puis il a
perdu en quarts de finale à moscou
d'ailleurs contre le joueur que ses fans
au maire va rencontrer demain soir et
donc il a considéré qu'il n'était pas en
forme qu'il avait perdu en quarts de
finale qu'ils voulaient pas venir à
blois et perdent encore quelque chose
une défection qui n'est pas rare à ce
niveau de compétition où les gains des
joueurs ici 35000 euros à se partager
incite certains d'entre eux a botté en
touche au dernier moment mais à blois
heureusement l'appât du gain n'est pas
le seul moteur des joueurs
on a un challenger
dans notre pib la plupart du temps on
essaie de le jouer surtout la plupart
habitent pas loin de paris et tous ces
cas une heure et demie de voiture c'est
beaucoup plus pratique c'est moins de
frais à prendre en compte et voilà en
plus les tourments il est sympa donc
raison plus une compétition réputée donc
pour sa convivialité et à laquelle
participe à nouveau le tenant du titre
maximo gonzalez qui fait ici figure de
grand favori le régional stéphane robert
chez lui à blois reste challengers de ce
tournoi qu'il n'a jamais remportée